[Music]
most people would agree that airlines
don't generally provide five-star
quality meals there's a reason the food
doesn't taste so great and there are
even more reasons why you should avoid
eating your in-flight meal all together
that you might not be aware of stick
around to find out why and make sure to
keep watching till the end to learn what
options you have if you really can't
wait until you land to chow down
if you've ever endured a long flight and
the questionable meals that come with it
make sure to give this video a thumbs up
and subscribe today we're showing you
the reasons why you should never eat
airplane food the food is not fresh
modern commercial airplanes are huge so
huge that some are even double deckers
unfortunately all that space translates
into what's profitable for the airline
company and a fully equipped kitchen
does not make the cuts typically the
in-flight meals are prepared in a
kitchen near the airport most meals are
either totally precooked or part cooked
such as chicken that is only 60 percent
code or steak that's cooked 30 percent
to done leaving the final cooking stage
to happen in the onboard infection ovens
after this great cooking process the
meals are rapidly chilled to 5 degrees
Celsius and then they wait in a
refrigerator near the gates before being
loaded onto the plane all of this pre
cooking and blast freezing preparation
usually happens a whopping 10 hours
before it's scheduled to be eaten by
passengers when real time finally does
roll around on the flight the flight
attendants get to work reheating the
meals in the convection ovens a process
that takes about 20 minutes this type of
oven uses a fan to blow hot air onto the
food allowing for a faster cooking and
reheating time and lower temperatures
that don't totally destroy the already
delicate food and render their meals
inedible while some people might be able
to stomach it or not totally convinced
on the idea of leaner meal that was
cooked and chilled 10 hours ago airlines
are cheap every airline is a business
and just like any other business their
main goal is profit how can they make
the most money possible cutting down on
individual passenger space say by taking
away an inch or two of leg space to make
room for more passengers is one way more
capacity equals more tickets to sell
which in turn means more profits these
companies are cutting corners everywhere
they can as long as it saves them a few
bucks or even
because it all adds up dramatically take
for example American Airlines who were
able to save 40 thousand dollars a year
simply by removing one single olive from
each of their individual in-flight
salads for another major airline that
scrapped olives in their salads
altogether this translated into savings
of three million dollars a year it might
only be a few cents save per passenger
but when you have around 80 million
passengers it adds up airlines
scrutinize every aspect in which saving
money is feasible and a lot of the time
your meals as the passenger are the
ultimate sacrifice they will seek out
the cheapest possible ingredients that
fit within their tight budgets so it's
probably best to avoid their cheaply
bought chicken or beef even mills you
can purchase and fight are only about as
quality as what you'd find pre-made at a
convenience store and they're really
just not worth the price in-flight meals
don't taste good this one is really down
to the individual
some people might be so hungry on their
flight but they don't care as much about
the taste but many people agree that the
food is not the best quality and doesn't
come with the best flavors if it's your
only option then you can't wait a few
more hours to eat a meal at your
destination sometimes you can convince
yourself with the airplane food tastes
good part of the reason for the less
than appetizing taste is due to the
reheating process the conditions for
making the food hot aren't ideal and
it's really the only choice the flight
crew has in order to heat your meal thus
flavor is sacrificed and you're left
with a disappointing meal reminiscent of
a frozen TV dinner right down to ripping
off the malleable plastic or aluminum
cover interestingly it's not all the
fault of the airline some of it comes
down to your biology and a little bit of
physics the dry air diminishes your
sense of smell the pressurization of the
cabin dulls your taste buds and even the
white noise from the hunting engine can
interfere with the way you perceive
taste these three side effects of flying
can create a recipe for disaster for
airlines when planning in-flight meals
that keep people happy without breaking
the bank
the food is ridiculously over-seasoned
to combat the inevitable dulling of
passengers senses while flying airlines
notoriously over-seasoned their
in-flight meals the two tastes that are
the most affected by low humidity low
air pressure and lots of background
noise common in the cabin environment
are saltiness and sweetness our ability
to taste sour bitter and umami flavors
usually escapes unscathed
unfortunately for us passengers however
this means loading more salt and sugar
into our meals to make them more
palatable among other spices and
seasonings the combination of sodium
rich food and a cabin literally drier
than a desert does not translate well
for people who want to avoid dehydration
on a flight this is especially true
given how scarce water seems to be when
flying with flight attendants giving you
the tiniest sip of bottled water from a
small plastic cup fit for a child but
not an adult's interestingly umami
flavors also known as savory flavors
seem to be enhanced by the conditions of
the cabin environments this would be a
good explanation for why so many people
request to drink tomato juice or even a
Bloody Mary when you're 35,000 feet in
the air and the only food available is
bland like rice a strong tasting savory
drink ends up sounding like the most
delectable thing in the world
airplane meals are not nutritious even
if your in-flight meal consists of
chicken rice and broccoli it's still
really not all that healthy an average
airplane meal contains about 1,500
calories and is loaded with fats salt
and sugar each individual item in your
meal usually has about 360 to 400
calories in it alone the reason for all
the additives like salt and sugar highs
back to the same issue with human taste
and the physics of the plane's cabin we
just can't taste salty and sweet on the
plane as we can at sea level catering
companies need to compensate for that
and inject absurd amounts of sugar and
salt into the flight meals so people
aren't unhappy without tastes an
estimated 15 to 20 percent more sugar is
added to in-flight meals just to make it
taste the way it would on the ground
no wonder you feel so groggy and tired
after eating on the flight all of these
additives combined with preparation
methods and ingredient sources give
enough reason for celebrity chefs like
Gordon Ramsay and Anthony Bourdain to
avoid airline food if there is anyone
you should trust on that matter it would
be professional chefs in case you wanted
to avoid
like a bit or eliminate feelings of
fatigue and a foggy head it's probably
best to do what they do and eat
something substantial before boarding
the plane and then treat yourself to a
nice meal when you land gastrointestinal
discomfort incredibly your digestive
system goes a little haywire at 35,000
feet in the air it's not to say that it
stops working but it does become a
little bit stressed ultimately leading
you to feel a touch bogged down yourself
if you already suffer from gas or
cramping for whatever reason these
problems can become significantly more
unbearable once you're in the skies this
is due to the air pressure in the cabin
being similar to the air pressure you
would experience at an altitude around
6,000 to 8,000 feet above sea level at
this altitude or simulation there of the
body puts more focus on more essential
functions and digestion efficiency is
just not one of them our body can adjust
to altitude '''l changes with time but
this process takes days and the flight
doesn't give it enough time to adapt
leading to digestive discomfort ideally
to avoid this gastrointestinal problem
it's best to just decline airline food
altogether if you don't give your poorly
operating digestive tract a chance to
start working while in the air you'll
feel less groggy and energy depleted
when you land simply because your body
doesn't have to ramp up your digestive
function to finish the job it started on
the plane if you must eat in the air
avoid foods that will contribute to this
problem such as beans broccoli and
greasy meat opt for lighter options
instead such as nuts carrots or poultry
unsanitary dining area this probably
isn't surprising but bacteria are
everywhere you have more bacterial cells
in your body than cells with your own
DNA and it's true there are bacteria all
over planes you have flown in that is no
excuse however for the deplorable
cleaning habits airlines develop
especially when considering that people
will be eating on their vessels a
two-year study by a team of
microbiologists and engineers from
Auburn University in Alabama found
something quite disturbing in properly
clean seats and tray tables provide a
home for e.coli and Mrs a a superbug
version of
in staph infection and they're capable
of surviving there for up to a week we
don't know about you but the idea of
eating food from a tray table that might
be harboring an antibiotic resistant
bacterium that causes a staph infection
is something we find very disturbing
worse yet the Federal Aviation
Administration doesn't enforce any rules
on how regularly an aircraft should be
cleaned this is left to the discretion
of the individual airline company which
means some planes could go a full month
without a proper deep-clean most
airlines use third-party cleaning
companies as well and the more hours a
plane has to stay grounded to be clean
less money the airline company is making
how thorough do you think they are if
you haven't rethought airline food yet
keep watching and you'll surely decline
a meal on your next flight the flight
crew eat differently did you know that
flight attendants don't always eat the
airplane food even if it's provided free
of charge many flight attendants prefer
to bring their own cold snacks and meals
so they have control over what they're
eating most concerns are related to the
nutritional content of in-flight meals
and how I'm appetizing they taste
there are several popular blog websites
giving tips specifically on how flight
attendants can a meal prep efficiently
and effectively simply because a vast
percentage of them prefer to avoid the
airplane food some closely knit crews
even coordinate meals like a sort of
potluck dinner party at 35,000 feet in
the air if so many members of the very
people serving me food choose to avoid
that food themselves why wouldn't you
perhaps the most unsettling bit of
information we learned is that
oftentimes when the pilot and co-pilot
are eating the airlines provided meals
they must choose different meals the
pilot usually gets the first-class meal
with the co pilot getting business class
this is to lower the risk of food
poisoning because having to food sick
islets flying your plane is a recipe for
disaster
next time you're starving on a long
flight and a flight attendant brings you
a meal don't forget to ask yourself if
you'd rather be hungry for a few hours
or potentially locked in the laboratory
with an upset stomach from the food what
about the drinks we hate to burst your
bubble even more but you should probably
avoid more than just airline food you
can say no to coffee and tea as well
if sanitation is a concern of yours this
is because the water used to make the
coffee and tea is stored in tanks of
the planes remember when we talked about
the frequency with which planes are
cleaned not only is it rare but those
tanks are extremely troublesome to clean
as well as such they're often laden with
bacteria and even ecoli has been found
clinging to the walls of the water tanks
that's ok you might be thinking if you
can't eat the food or drink the coffee
or tea at least you can relax with a
glass of wine right wrong alcohol and
flying do not make very good friends due
to the lower amount of oxygen in the
cabin the alcohol can be metabolized
faster causing the feelings of
drunkenness to be exasperated and
leading you closer to potential altitude
sickness if you overdo the drinking and
become belligerent you can even be
arrested on landing it wouldn't be the
first time it's happened even if you
don't overdo the drinking alcohol will
leave you dehydrated in an environment
where there is already little humidity
do us all a favor
skip the booze and ask for a glass of
water from a water bottle instead your
only options if the thought of enduring
a 6 + hour long flight with no food no
drink not even a coffee to enjoy and
makes you cringe we do have some
solutions for you first you could just
see the filling mill a few hours before
you take off you'll feel energized be
less grumpy and won't feel tempted by
the smells of the cabins dinner and
while you're at it purchase a couple of
healthy nourishing snacks while you wait
for the boarding time it'll keep you
satiated the entire duration of the
flight and snacking can be fun
mindless activity to enhance your
endless movie binge finally if you crave
and feel that you absolutely must eat
the airplane food opt for dishes that
are super saucy the philosophy of
weather is better is standard among
airplane food this is because sauce
keeps food moist if the thought of
eating chicken reminiscent of sawdust
with a side of hard rice makes you
shudder opt for the juiciness and
decadence of a beef bourguignon instead
a stew is a fantastic option if you want
to eat airline food that tastes and
feels like it would on the ground the
nature of the stew isn't ruined by the
reheating that occurs on the plane you
can reheat us to a thousand times and it
will still be a tasty stew next time you
fly you'll know what to order and that's
it for this is why you should never eat
airplane food if you enjoyed our video
make sure to check out 10 secrets flight
attendants don't want you to know thanks
for watching and see you in our next
video
[Music]